in a free and democratic process the
British people have expressed their wish
to leave the European Union we regard
this decision personally I'm very sad
about this decision but of course we
have to respect it
this is an unprecedented situation but
we are united in our response we will
stand strong and uphold the European
Union's core values promoting peace and
the well-being of its peoples the union
of 27 member states will continue the
union is the framework of our common
political future we are bound together
by history geography come in twist and
we develop our cooperation on this basis
together with the rest our common
challenges to generate growth increase
prosperity and ensure a safe and secure
environment for our citizens the
institutions will play the full toll in
this endeavor we now expect the United
Kingdom government to give effect to
this decision at the British people as
soon as possible however painful the
process may be any delay with
unnecessary prolong uncertainty we have
goods to deal with this in an orderly
way article 50 of the treaty on European
Union sets out the procedures to be
followed if a member states this set
decides to leave European Union we stand
ready to launch negotiations swiftly
swiftly with the UK regarding the terms
and conditions of its withdrawal from
the European Union and until this
process of negotiations is over
the United Kingdom remains a member of
the European Union with all rights and
with all obligations that derive from
this according to the treaties with the
United Kingdom has ratified EU law
continues to apply to the third - and in
the United Kingdom until is no longer it
is no longer man as a grid the new
settlement for the United Kingdom within
the European Union which that you've
been counting in February this year we
will now not take effect and ceases to
exist there will be no regen och
there will be no renegotiation as
regards the United Kingdom we hope to
have it as a close partner of European
Union in the future we expect United
Kingdom to formulate its proposals in
this respect an agreement which will be
good which will be concluded with UK as
a third country will have to reflect the
interests of both sides and be balanced
in terms of rights and in terms of
obligations